Theresa May has accused Nicola Sturgeon
of constitutional game-playing after the
Scottish First Minister announced plans
yesterday to call a second referendum on
independence mr. speaker the new
relationship the new relationship with
the EU that we negotiate will work for
the whole of the United Kingdom that is
why we have been working closely with
the devolved administration's
[Applause]
including including the Scottish
government listening to their proposals
and recognizing the many areas of common
ground that we have such as protecting
workers rights and our security from
crime and terrorism
so Mr Speaker this is not a moment to
play politics or create answer
well the Prime Minister may have
insisted it wasn't a time to play
politics but Nicola Sturgeon tweeted to
point out that the SNP vote in Scotland
was far higher than the conservative
vote in the general election and then
she followed it up with this in addition
I was elected as First Minister on a
clear manifesto commitment re Scot
breath the Prime Minister is not yet
elected by anyone Leanne Anderson is
co-founder the communications agency
cicero's specializing in political risk
and economic policy issues so in
presumably this Scottish business needed
this like a hole in the head all this
extra uncertainty yeah well I mean layer
on layer of uncertainty in just some
extent though I mean what's been the
reaction so far
I mean markets have been quite becomed
by this there's no volatile reaction why
because Nicola Sturgeon has been saying
this really since November 2014 this is
priced in the thing that's directly in
front of most businesses is brexit not
stopped rescue money of EF or whatever
you want to call it about the economics
of this so in I mean Scotland's notional
deficits last year would have been 9%
twice that of the UK as a whole I'm
gonna vote for independence and I would
essentially be a vote for austerity
wouldn't it well I mean there's
something else going on here
in it's not economics anymore that seems
to win elections looking at the brexit
votes
looking at Trump you know what the
politics of identity again and again
beat the economic argument and I think
of a lot of firms are looking to make
the economic argument this time around
they might think that that falls on
pretty stony ground and I think that's
what the Nationalists are gonna try to
do is identify don't put near food on
the table their roof over people's heads
does it well yeah it depends kind of
where you are look what there was a very
emotional reaction as we discussed
before in the immediate aftermath of the
Bridget vote actually 400,000 voters
have swapped sides in terms of
supporting independence or not they've
almost cancelled each other out there's
a lot going on underneath the headlines
business this time though has to be very
very careful about how it enters this
conversation Nicola Sturgeon missed time
this though in because if you look at
oil prices I mean in 2011-2012
Scotland's share of North Sea oil
revenues would have been around ten
billion nine point six billion last year
have been just sixty million without
recovering the oil price I mean where do
they go yeah I mean you know folks like
you analysts the market are going to
keep asking those questions
the SNP are I would say is not gonna get
into that debate at all I think what
business really really has to watch out
for is a completely different zeitgeist
that's donek going on in modern scotland
viewed from here in london i I don't
think people decode that properly
they're not gonna get into the same kind
of debate that was played out it's gonna
be a very different kind of conversation
to the conversation that took place in
2014
well you're a Scot you build a built a
successful business down here in London
if the UK leaves the EU as we assume it
will doing an independent Scotland is
the only way of getting back into the
single market would you be tempted to go
north of the border well I might have an
option of a Scottish passport I probably
would give them what the nationalists
have said so far look I mean like every
business we will look at the
circumstances as they fall there's a
long way to go the polls 50/50 at the
moment